leave me alone no never I don't want you
to leave me alone I want you to be here
all the time it's great to see you again
I'm here as your cultural music Maven as
Mr hip hop himself Wonder Mike I've come
to say hello and to listen to a song by
NF I recently covered a song by NF on
this show and probed it without any
knowledge of who this man is or what he
talks about just interpreting what I
could from the work of art itself and
people seem to like it so we're going to
do another song This is called leave me
alone it has 106 million views again
this is the second thing I've ever heard
from this guy I have not heard it yet I
am seeing this totally fresh face so I
may say things that you know contradict
some aspect of Mr F's biography I don't
know I'm just going to tell you what I
see on the screen and what it means even
if it contradicts something that the
artist himself has said okay take it
away
hey
[Music]
leave me alone Panic stricken handle
business not a joke yeah manners missing
travel different no control yeah time to
listen time to zip it keep it close my
description highly gifted take some
notes yeah lack of Interest why'd you
visit hit the road yeah kind of Twisted
so keep your distance be a ghost yeah
see I'm invented but quite the Menace
you ain't know well then I'm offended
let's talk your memories here we go yeah
I went from nobody to kind of famous
hide my plaques inside the closet I just
can't explain it my wife she tells me
that she's piled and thinks that I
should hang them but I just leave them
on the ground right next to myself
hatred yeah yeah mental health where's
my mental health diagnose with OCD what
does that mean we'll gather around that
means I obsessively obsess on things I
think about that means I might take a
normal thought and think it's so
profound ruminating
what he's describing seems ironic to
some people that you could be lauded for
your efforts and win all sorts of
plaques and awards and that you would
you would want to bury those things in
your closet but this frequently happens
sometimes it's called imposter syndrome
the idea that you don't feel that you
really deserve the success or the
recognition that you've received and it
could just be plain old narcissism that
very often it's the people who are most
likely to brag about themselves who feel
the smallest about themselves that that
is an ordinary thing and the solution to
it I'm not the first to say it is not to
think less of yourself but to think of
yourself less it's a that's a hard trick
to do the fact that he links it to
obsessive compulsive disorder I don't
know if he actually has that condition
but but what OCD does is it has you
focus obsessively on these really real
really minor things which robs even the
receipt of of some kind of Award of the
joy of that because you find the one
little thing that's wrong the one little
strand of the carpet that's off kilter
and it just drives you right you've got
to straighten everything out comb
everything out and and it just drives
you crazy and deprived and depletes The
Joy from the experience
hold on my balloons and cover up my face
I can feel them Weighing on me every day
I should let them go and watch them
float away but I'm scared if I do then
I'll be more afraid tell them how I feel
but they don't want to change tell them
how I feel but they remain the same
loosen up by grip they say that's not
okay quiet quiet
leave me alone
I hate when they debate it for
underrated we're so overlooked that
they're looking over our numbers Nathan
we don't do enough interviews or go out
in public lately we don't post enough on
our socials to keep the bus from fading
let it
fade once it's decimated then you drop a
song out of nowhere and all the fans
embrace it and the puzzle surface again
it's part of my operation I don't need
advice from my Yachts right now end of
conversations put a pause there I love
this and and this is one spot where I
take it that this guy has all sorts of
problems with drugs and he clearly has
some mental problems that he's talking
about in in the song that I can't
directly relate to but the one thing I
can directly relate to here is that I am
a content creator that is my job and I
know exactly what he's talking about
which is oh wow you had a big hit you
had something break away whether it's a
book or an interview or an episode or
whatever it is okay well what's the
first thing that happens you never get
to just take a moment sit back and say
okay that was good now we'll wait for
the next
idea to come up no what happens is
immediately all the publicity people and
all of the consultants and all the
marketers to say okay well we've got to
maintain the momentum you're not doing
nearly enough I know you just went from
zero to here but you you're way
underrated you got to go from here to
here and and it can feel as though you
you are never able to catch what you are
chasing and he's describing that with
the song he says no I I let the buzz die
down the buzz is going to die down then
I'm gonna have another thought and
that'll that'll Buzz up again come on
leave me alone I don't need any more
doubts because because what he's
describing in the first part of the song
Too is the more successful he becomes
the the more praised he is
the more doubts there are and he's
holding on to these doubts and these
burdens and these traumas that he's
experienced in these balloons that's
what the balloons are symbolizing he
says I just I want to let them go but
then I feel that I'm I fear rather that
I might even be more afraid because I'm
going to let them go I'm going to lose a
whole lot of my identity and so
paradoxically the better things seem to
be going the worse one feels and and I
think everybody in their own lives has
experienced this to some degree here's a
little secret you're not going to have
peace until you ground that peace and
the good that you're searching for and
who who is synonymous with the good okay
keep going
foreign
[Applause]
on me every day I should let them go and
watch them float away but I'm scared if
I do then I'll be more afraid tell them
how I feel but they don't want to change
tell them how I feel but they remain the
same loosening up my grip they say
that's not okay quiet quiet hey leave me
alone
be quiet yeah leave me
the point is there is that quiet quite
quiet leave me alone I loosen up my grip
but they say that's not okay he's
talking about these these burdens and
perhaps even these vices and perhaps
even these sins that have taken control
of his life and what he's describing is
not delusional I think a lot of people
listen to this and they say oh you're
just suffering from a delusion a kind of
dysmorphia because you do have all of
this success and you have this talent
and and you've got all this popular
Acclaim and in your mind you're saying I
don't really deserve that or I'm still a
fallen broken terrible degenerate person
and and what a lot of people watching
are going to say is no no what you're
hearing in your mind that's false what
he's saying is yeah I got all these
audits I got all the success I've got
all these new responsibilities I've got
this whole path to make another hit
after hit after hit but these balloons
that I'm holding on to they're not
they're telling me no you're still the
same person and so while our sins and
our vices and our our broken character
and habits of of virtue perverted device
the fact that they are there does remain
and that really does tell you something
and this is why people who become really
rich and who become really famous often
become miserable at the end of the night
it doesn't matter if you're going to bed
in a little Shack or if you're going to
bed in a big mansion in Malibu if you
are just riddled by addiction and pride
and and envy and gluttony and wrath and
lust and all these terrible deadly sins
well it doesn't matter if you've got all
the money and all the success and all
the awards in the world that is still
going to be gnawing at your soul and and
so he's not mistaken to believe that
that is a real problem that he has to
confronted don't pretending pretend we
needed low percentage so demented all
consensus is so tremendous no Apprentice
nope incentive show intensive so
possessive don't aggressive watch your
step one night hold on my balloons and
cover up my face I can feel them
Weighing on me every day every day I
should let them go and watch them float
away I'm scared if I do it and I'll be
more afraid I love this image of your
texting Fame your Fame comes to you and
says hey you want to do something
together and you say no I'm not that
interested it doesn't feel right okay
and then he says NF the character says
Hey Fame hey I got you I got this song I
think it's pretty good and any artist
knows anyone who's ever created anything
out of his own originality through his
own artistic skill
hey there's such a vulnerability when
you say here is my artistic vision
and you're waiting he doesn't get a text
back and he doesn't get a text back
finally Fame says yeah that song sucked
and it's a devastate it's devastating
because you can find yourself if you are
in public life really at all especially
if you're in the Arts
chasing Fame earlier on when NF wasn't
as focused on Fame and wasn't in the
thrall of Fame he would just make the
art and he didn't care Fame calls him he
says yeah whatever I'll call you I don't
need to talk to you right now but then
as you get a little more into it and you
hear all of those Buzzy people from the
earlier part of the song I say buzz buzz
buzz we got to keep up the buzz all of a
sudden now NF starts changing his focus
and he starts to chase Fame and then
fame fame is a Fickle lady and fame says
not song sucked so now he's he's lost
he's desperately chasing this this car
he's the dog chasing this car that he's
not going to catch up to the car just
keeps pulling further and further away
Fame can also be a problem when you're
the dog that does catch the car not to
bring it back to religion again but I
guess I am trying to bring it back to
religion because ultimately that's what
all of this is really talking about
these these spiritual sicknesses but if
you start chasing these Idols of this
world you're going to end up in a really
bad spot as the protagonist of the song
is leave me alone leave me alone all
right leave me alone
[Applause]
there he is and he brings his burden to
what the song ends he's handing his
burdens over to a hand in a lab coat I
assume the hand in the lab coat is
representative of drugs of
pharmaceuticals and saying you know I
can't leave me alone leave me alone
while you were not leaving me alone why
don't you leave me alone and so we can
temporarily numb our troubles with
things like drugs or food or drink or
sex or or even wrath or even all you can
numb it with all sorts of of sins but
that's that's not going to be conducive
to happiness in the long run which he
knows that's why he's been pushing this
card along trying to deal with his
problems the whole time but then when it
gets so loud it's so like you can't stop
they won't leave him alone then he gives
in to temptation
which people often do which is why we
got to confess and why we got to try to
fix the real root problems here and
repent and turn our eyes toward our true
good because all these all these
fleeting desires Fame Fortune
drugs all the rest of it those
ultimately will not make us happy they
can be good in their proper sphere
you can you can do good things if you've
got some Fame you can do good things
with money and money can be good to keep
a roof over your head and keep your
family fed even drugs as medicine can
serve a purpose in the proper place but
but when you pursue them as an end unto
yourself then you end up
stomping around
in an immense amount of pain like the
protagonist of the song and then you
fall again into temptation which is
something one does not want to do okay
I'm Michael Knowles we'll see you next
time